foreign
Charlie joins us in Dallas Texas Charlie
welcome to the show
hello thanks for taking my call sure how
can we help
um I am about 135 000 that
um
85 000 of it is about student loans and
then I got two cars
my wife makes about 2 000 a month and I
make
anywhere from 38 to six thousand dollars
a month and I do not know how to get us
out of that
well I'm glad you called us man are you
a new listener how long you been
listening to the show
um on and off for a few years but
religiously for the last three weeks so
what made you call us today versus three
years ago
um I am tired of not being able to sleep
ah there you go that's a good place to
be and it's a bad place to be but it's
good because you're ready to get out
aren't you and you're willing to do
whatever it takes now
yes and you guys are bringing home
anywhere from six to eight k a month
total
yes okay that's good news
now these car loans what are the cars
worth
um one of them is worth five thousand
and I owe eight thousand and the other
one's worth probably 12 and I owe I
think 18 000 on it so you're underwater
on both of these things
yes okay
well how much money do you have saved in
the bank
uh zero
how little can you live on out of that
six to eight thousand a month what are
your actual expenses
we I've looked it up and I believe it's
about
five thousand
you have five thousand in expenses
yes do you guys own a home in what
um we owe we pay 1500 a month in our
rent and then one car's 500 the other
car is 280 our utilities are about 250 a
month cell phones we pay almost 400 a
month 400 for cell phones
uh for four of us yes wow you guys are
getting ripped off man big time
uh that's T-Mobile for you
no that's way too much that is not
T-Mobile's fault that's you you they can
charge whatever they want to charge you
signed up for it man
yeah okay so you're A1 I'm gonna get you
on an every dollar budget and I'm gonna
gift you the premium version for a year
if you're willing to do it
thank you but here's what that means you
are going to track every transaction
like a madman and before you make any
decision you're gonna ask yourself does
this help me become debt free and find
the freedom that I've desperately been
looking for
okay and when you do that here's what
you're going to do you're going to go
why are we paying 400 bucks we got to
find a better deal we're switching cell
phone companies today who are the four
people in your family
um my two kids my wife and I how old are
the kids
16 and 13. they can participate
they can get jobs and help out with a
hundred dollar a month cell phone bill
good God almighty all right
I'm gonna also gift you Financial Peace
University is your wife on board with
this or is it just you yes she is she's
fully
yes okay we need to find out where all
this 8 000 is going because you're
telling me even if your expenses are
five you have an extra three to throw at
the debt
yes can you work overtime where's the
variable pay come in
um I'm an independent contractor
um I usually work
10 hours a day
um 10 to 12 about six days a week
and what is your wife doing for work
um she is she works for the school
district
okay hold on hold on you're an
independent contractor
you're an independent contractor working
10 hour day six days a week and you make
about 70 000 bucks a year
yes you need to find another job you're
either not doing very well as an
independent contractor
or you are being dramatically underpaid
but you are killing yourself for seventy
thousand bucks
you can go drive a truck for what for
that that annual amount of money
okay you see what I'm saying what do you
do like the the the general contractors
if I can get one to call me back right
now for work at my house that I'll pay
with cash there I mean it's a premium
for the for the privilege of coming out
to my house just to look at it
are you not charging enough
um I work uh delivery service so it uh I
get paid by what they offer for the
delivery
okay
do you like this work
yes and it works with our scheduling of
everything that we got going on okay
George is walking you through this
there's only two things you can do with
money you can cut expenses or you can
make more of it
okay and I want you to do both yeah if
this job is taking your like it takes
every last hour of your life and that's
what it gets you it might be working for
your family schedule wise but it might
make paying this debt off take five
years instead of three or six years
instead of two
so it might work for you every week it
might not work for you long term okay
okay now you said you were 135 in in
debt but the numbers aren't quite adding
up because you said you had 85 in
student loans and two car loans but the
two car loans don't add up to 50K
and then we have uh two uh loans we took
out and then which
I think we are about 800 left on it we
have three credit cards
and then uh our medical debt that we
have
how old is the medical debt
um
anywhere from 10 years to just recent
okay you need to call and negotiate that
today
but you need to scrape together some
money to throw at it how much is the
total medical debt
um last time I looked I think we owed
like
13 000 total okay you're gonna need to
scrape together maybe four or five
thousand and call them and say listen I
can pay you four or five thousand if you
call it good and settle in full and then
writing
and beyond that we're going to pay off
the smallest to largest regardless of
interest rates and start attacking this
debt if that means you need a personal
loan because you're underwater on the
cars to get out of these and get two
really cheap beater cars to get you
around to speed this up I'm okay with
that but we've got to start making some
drastic decisions if we want to see
progress
and that means maybe your wife is going
to find a different job because she's
getting paid minimum wage working for
the school district
you don't seem to like our answers
no no uh it's good advice
it's okay if you don't you're a grown
man you can you can do whatever you want
to it's just I don't think you recognize
how radical you got to get to pay this
135 000 off
it's gonna take some work man hang on
the line Austin's gonna pick up we're
gonna gift you FPU and every dollar and
I'm gonna give you four tickets to our
smart conference event in Dallas and I
want to see you when we come out during
the breaks I want to see Charlie from
Dallas say dude I'm all in this event is
part of that Journey my wife is here my
kids are here we are all in on this
thing so hang on the line we're gonna
get you the whole kitten caboodle to get
you on this journey but you've got to
want it more than we do man